hello grammarians today we're going to
be talking about the irregular plural
previously I had said that if you take
any English word any noun say the word
dog and you tack an S on to the end of
it like so
Boop you get the word dogs and that's
how you form the plural in all cases I
was lying sorry it turns out that
English is a little bit more complicated
than that while adding an S to things is
the way you usually make things plural
sometimes there are other changes and
sometimes you don't even pluralize using
an S at the end but we're not going to
talk about that now that's for another
time what I want to talk about today is
the most basic kind of irregular plural
so we have the difference in English
between regular and irregular plurals
and remember a plural is when there's
more than one of something it comes from
the Latin plus which means more as
opposed to the singular when there is
just one of something you know one one
dog two dogs so there's a handful of
words in English and it really is a
handful that don't PluralEyes regularly
words like leaf and loaf and calf it's a
big cow if you try to pluralize these as
though they were regular plurals you're
going to return something that is not
correct or at least is not conventional
within modern standard American English
right so Leafs for example unless you're
talking about the Toronto hockey team is
not correct in fact the proper term
boop-boop boop-boop boop-boop is in fact
leaves it is not loafs but lowe's tasty
loaves of bread
it is not calf's but cow
so there are several different kinds of
irregular plurals that's why this video
is called part 1 but I'm only going to
cover one such irregular plural today
and that is the change from singular F
to plural ve so if you see a word
generally that ends in F the plural is
going to become ve you can learn
anything Dave it out